hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
one of the central components in
aristotle's definition of anger and
rhetoric book two is the action
and the suffering of sliding the person
who angers
slights the other person who then
suffers or undergoes this sliding and
the word sliding is a translation of
oleguria it could be rendered in other
ways making less
belittling pushing down there's a lot of
different ways we could characterize
this and aristotle in fact is going to
provide us with a definition of what
sliding is
it's a little bit tricky in the way
that it's framed it can be defined as
actualization of opinion in regard to
something which appears
valueless now when you hear that if you
don't automatically or intuitively say
oh yes i understand exactly what he's
talking about it's in part because of
the language so the actualization
is en ergaea right and this is an
important aristotelian term particularly
in in metaphysics but it also pertains
to ethical and emotional
matters so actualization is a good way
to translate it it's making something
b making something
act within the world that we live in so
sliding
takes
something and makes it actual what does
it
make actual opinion doksa and doxa can
mean opinion in the sense of an opinion
that i have in my mind but it's also
sort of like your public existence your
reputation is another way of translating
it
it's you could think of this as
making something
clear within the public sphere or
advancing
a claim about somebody or something and
what is it
saying so
it's in regard or in relation to
perry in greek
tomedenos
and that means uh the
thing maedenos
oxione is going to be
of no account of no value
oxios oxione you know here means value
it's the word that we get axiom from
right something that we consider to be
valuable
and so something is being treated
as if it is of no value or little value
and the key word there following that
is finomenon whole phenomenon something
that you know is in
our public site you could say something
that appears right so actualization of
opinion in regard to something which
appears valueless making it
appear
of less value than it is or showing
that you don't consider it
valuable and this could be with you know
physical objects like i could say this
piece of chalk is just crap i'm going to
show how valueless it is snap i break it
in half it can do nothing to resist me
right that's probably not going to get
you angry but if i say you know
i i'm really glad that i'm not as stupid
as you
now suddenly i'm slighting you right i
am telling you that i consider you to be
stupid and if you are in fact stupid you
might say well yes okay i i accept that
but if you don't feel stupid which i
think most people don't you would say
who the hell are you to call me stupid
i want to be treated better than that
right and so sliding
is treating people in in ways
that they don't like that they
view as
putting them down lowering them in a
certain respect
and aristotle is going to define three
main
modalities of this
is this all that you know we could
possibly conceive of in terms of sliding
probably not and
some of the examples are sometimes a bit
difficult to fit in but this is a pretty
good
rendition or explanation of what it is
that people get angry about and the
three kinds that he names are we can
translate these in different ways
contempt disdain sometimes it's
translated as literally
looking down or thinking down about
somebody cataphronesis
spite
aberrasmos
you know malice is another way perhaps
of translating this
just screwing with people would be a
rather colloquial way and then we've got
this term that we can render as insult
it's not a bad way to render it we're
more familiar with this as an anglicized
greek term hubris
right we often talk about somebody being
you know full of hubris because they're
taking on more than they can actually
deliver this is a little bit different
so hubris was a term that was used in
ancient greek not just to denote people
who were like super prideful and like
you know took a city and became the
tyrant
but also people who would engage in
insult or injury or attempts to
humiliate with each other to screw with
somebody in a way that's a little bit
different than spite as we'll talk about
in a moment and aristotle is going to
give us a
little description of each of these and
then some examples and then he's going
to go on
and provide additional examples within
this chapter of book two so let's look
at contempt first right contempt is
treating
somebody as of no
or little value the term that he uses
there is oxyon again
so treating somebody
regardless of what value they have
as if they don't really have value and
aristotle actually says something quite
interesting here
things which are really bad or good or
tend to become so
we consider worthy of paying attention
to so if somebody's really bad you know
then you watch out for them right if
something is really good you pay
attention to it things that we don't
care about
those are the things we look down upon
we show contempt to
so this can vary considerably from
person to person and situation to
situation
and um he's going to go on as well and
tell us
about spite what is spite consistent
literally placing
obstacles hindering you could say
as well
and podesmos these are
shackles or things that get in the way
of somebody doing something placing
obstacles
in the way of
other people's wishes what it is that
they want what it is
that they
desire and then he goes on and he says
not in order
that any advantage
accrues to him who spite so they're not
getting anything out of it they're just
preventing anything good happening for
the other person this is malice this is
maliciousness this is
uh being a a jerk to other people now
there's another way of being a jerk
though
hubris
injuring blaberon right in in greek or
causing pain lupe
to another in order to and here we got
to be a little bit careful with the
translations well to cause them disgrace
to cause them literally
shame
um
to lower them in that respect
um
here the greek is
uh
f hois is right so that they feel
worse they feel shameful they feel
dishonored and aristotle will in fact
use the word atymia which means dishonor
as well to talk about this now why does
somebody do this
he says not to obtain any other
advantage for oneself besides the
performance of the act
but
for one's pleasure or we could translate
it as
their enjoyment in greek all hopos jesus
so that they they literally so that they
enjoy so that they feel pleasure
this is something that we see
people doing all the time
in
ways that could be innocuous like gentle
teasing
all the way up to bullying where one
increases one's own sense of status or
agency at the expense of somebody else
who's humiliated who's forced into a
lowered position so each of these is a
particular
way in which we can slight and you might
make people angry by being contemptuous
of them but not by being insulting or
you could just be a spiteful person who
doesn't get anything out of screwing
with other people screwing up their
plans their wishes their desires and you
don't actually show contempt or insult
these are all different
possible modalities and then aristotle
is going to give us some some nice
examples of this he talks
about
here we go
people
who are
showing contempt to
other people dishonoring them right he
says that people think that they have a
right to be esteemed by those who are
inferior to them in birth and power and
virtue or whatever other
respect and so if you treat them as if
they're equal or lower then they get
upset with you
for this right
he says people are angry at slights from
those whom they think they have a right
to expect to be well treated those
they've conferred or are conferring
benefits right those who they desire or
did desire to benefit and there's a lot
of ways of showing contempt one that
we're going to talk about
in
as its own thing but i'll just mention
here
if you
talk badly about something that somebody
else
considers to be important or serious and
you treat it as if it's not
they get angry with you because they
feel that you're sliding not them as
such but the things that that concern
them
let's talk about spite a little bit more
so aristotle actually
has a very interesting discussion where
he doesn't mention
spite but i think this is exactly what
he's talking about he says that people
are angry when they are pained because
one who is pained aims at something if
then anyone directly opposes them in
anything as for example prevents them
from drinking when they're thirsty or
not directly but just seems to be doing
the same
and if anyone goes against him or
refuses to assist him or troubles him in
any other way when he's in this frame of
mind he is angry with all such persons
now that is an example of placing
obstacles placing things that get in the
way somebody desires something you
don't let them have what it is that they
desire you create problems for them
they're going to get angry and they're
going to get angry at you
for slighting them by showing spite they
may not articulate it that way
they may say things like why are you
getting in the way why are you messing
with me what's what's your problem here
but we're really talking about spite
here and so he gives some examples the
sick
those in
necessity those at war the lovesick the
thirsty in a word all who desire
something
and cannot attain it are prone to anger
and easily excited
now it's interesting because he also
talks a little bit here about contempt
what's the contempt angle he says
especially against those who make light
of their present condition who says it's
not that serious that's not that big of
a deal
make light could also be understood as
being a type of insult as we'll talk
about so he says
the sick person is easily provoked in
regard to his illness the necessities in
regard to his poverty the warrior in
regard to warlike affairs the lover in
regard to love affairs and so with the
rest for the passion
present
in his mind in each case paves the way
for his
anger right and aristotle also talks
about one other thing that's
in a way a projection on our part of
spite
people are angry when the event is
contrary to their expectation the more
unexpected a thing is the more it pains
just as they're overjoyed if contrary to
expectation
what they desire comes to pass so it
could be just circumstances i go walking
outside and i've got my
nice suede jacket on and it begins to
rain on me and i'm like oh damn you sky
rain clouds what are you doing to me
right that's you know
the the environment itself is showing me
a kind of spite
right maybe it's also showing me a kind
of contempt oh i don't really care about
you and your needs but it really has to
do much more with my desire to wear my
suede jacket which will now be ruined by
the the rain or something like that
right
let's talk about uh hubris insult this
is also something that makes people
quite angry right he says that
when this happens
the pleasure that's felt by those who
insult is the idea that in treating
other people badly
they're more fully
showing a kind of superiority
literally to be placed above the other
person so i think bullying is a prime
example of this bullies hurt other
people so that they can feel better
about themselves usually they're they're
not feeling great about themselves
either so he says
dishonor is characteristic of this and
one who dishonors another slights him
for that which is worthless has no value
either as
good or evil and he gives the example
of achilles in his wrath
proclaiming he has dishonored me since
he keeps the prize he has taken for
himself if you don't know about the
iliad it begins with achilles almost
losing it in anger and killing his war
leader agamemnon who has imposed a
sliding upon him taking it as as insult
so these are all the different kinds of
sliding that aristotle will talk about
in rhetoric book two as the provokers of
anger and knowing what these are we are
you could say better armed for
thinking about whether other people are
doing these to us when we get angry at
them
and for thinking about uh how we might
avoid doing these things if we don't
want to make other people
angry at us
you